j'aimerais bien voir plus
une perspective européenne dans le débat
allemand là-dessus
c'est certainement mon rôle en tant que
chercheur à Berlin de mettre un accent
sur
les questions européennes dans le débat
dans les débats allemands mais il faut
aussi dire que c'est la guerre c'est
quand même un choc un bouleversement
très très significatif et on voit dans
tous les pays en Europe à mon avis
le système politique
régale plus à l'intérieur
c'est
les citoyens c'est les électeurs
domestiques qui devient plus important
dans une situation de stress avec
beaucoup d'inflation avec une hausse des
prix d'énergie
une insécurité par rapport à la
situation de la guerre on voit partout
que les politiciens regardent un peu
chez soi
évidemment ça c'est le grand danger
c'est le grand danger pour notre
autonomie stratégique c'est un grand
danger pour notre capacité
de gagner cette guerre c'est une un
grand un grand défi
pour la sécurité européenne